just one year ago today nevada's first
confirmed covid patient also known as
patient zero was admitted to the
hospital joe moeller was there
covering this story one year ago and
today he spoke to him
about how far we have come he brings us
a story from the v.a hospital up in
north las vegas
when ronald pimpkins came here to the va
copin 19 did not even cross his mind now
one year later
he has a message for others
i think about those days leading up to
actually going to the hospital in
february 2020 ronald pimpkins went on a
trip with family to washington
i had no taste
um the actual last night i was
in washington seattle i had shivers
and i was cold and i didn't know what
was up it wasn't until he returned home
to las vegas when things got worse
on march 2nd he went to the va hospital
after being here
less than an hour they said my oxygen
level was very low
he was put in a coma as doctors tried to
figure out what was wrong
that's the last i remember until i woke
up at the end of march
pipkins was diagnosed with coping 19. he
did not get out of the hospital until
april
thank goodness that the governor put the
restrictions in place that he did
because if he wouldn't have
so many people in the state of nevada
would have died last week pipkins
received the copa 19 vaccine my daughter
went through so much
so much pain mentally of seeing her dad
lay in a coma
i i said to myself for my family
i'll i'll do it with three vaccines
available he helps more people
get their shot i wasn't given the
opportunity
to safeguard myself from this virus
but we all have that opportunity now
and so we all come together as a nation
we can get rid of this virus and we can
get on with our lives
pimpkins also thanked the staff and
medical professionals here at the va who
he says
saved his life reporting in north las
vegas joe moeller 8 news now